come on we're so close all we need to do
is to decide how we're gonna end the
pitch I say we end with a simple pie
chart numbers and statistics demonstrate
that we mean business or we come up with
a really catchy slogan and slap it over
some awesome clipart Elliott what do you
think is it hot in here
Elliott you want to go home right not
really me and my cat are in a fight
right now so right but you want me to go
home yeah sure okay so vote for my way
the digital high-five that's a fair
you're pressuring him I most certainly
am NOT is he pressuring you Oh yet could
tell me what now you're pressuring him
to say that I'm pressuring him I'm gonna
go get some water I'm parched
look my way is the clear winner we end
with cold hard facts evidentiary proof
that we deliver hmm there's a surprise
Anna wants to be cold and emotionless
companies like to know the bottom line
here's the bottom line
next segue Thanks the bottom line is
companies want to know that we have
their back my way is about heart with
nothing concrete and specific to back it
up your way is all based on Talk sound
familiar
Elliot isn't my way the company you'd
want to hire I
I feel like anything is business we
should end the pitch letting them know
that we're professionals I know what
you're gonna say that this is about
compromise no one was going to say that
maybe we can call Charlie and see what
do you think no Elliot this is your
moment oh I don't want a moment which is
it Elliot me or Cailin yeah Elliot who's
right what you guys are both right you
both have valid points and ya know
what's smell great
both good people so I'm gonna just
professionals here so I don't know why
you have to bring me in the middle of
this whole thing I just wanna go home
and make up with my cat mr. Harris so I
guess we'll go with mine all right I
didn't really care that much anyway hey
Mark